everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 4 of
our coverage of the 2018 candidates
tournament winner of this tournament
does go on to face Magnus Carlsen in the
world championship in November our two
competitors today are currently leading
why it's gonna be played by Vladimir
Kramnik he is a half a point ahead of
the field in playing black that is
Fabiano Caruana
he is a half a point behind in second
place so this is a huge match these
players will face each other one more
time where Fabiano will have the white
pieces but definitely with two of the
the best chess players in the field
squaring off it's always going to be a
firework so we're going to get started
with pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 getting into the petrov opening and
then after Knight takes here pawn to d6
this is the normal variation kicking the
knight back and then after that comes
here I was expecting to see the normal
main line which would be pawn to d4
sometimes you'll see Knight to c3 in the
petrov defense usually this is a varied
Rallis line which makes a lot of sense
for these two players they don't want to
get too carried away they are leading
the tournament and so there's no reason
for anyone to get out of line too much
then we see Queens Hui 2 Queen East 7
and after Knight c3 and they exchanged
pawn at capturing here then we see the
Queen's come off the board now if the
petrov is a very draw opening exchanging
the Queens off the board after only 8
moves is even more so on the draw side
but we will continue Knight here to see
six simple development Bishop to e3
Bishop e7 castle on the queenside castle
on the kingside so if we have anything
goes going for us as fans is that both
sides decided to castle on opposite
sides which just means they can throw
everything they want at their opponent's
side and start a strong attack rook here
to e1 Bishop to f6 so both sides just
developing their pieces just as they
normally would Knight back here to d2
rook to e8 just
attacking the center of the board here
Bishop to f3 a night here to be 5 and
then Bishop to f4 this is being
protected this Bishop here on f3 the
knight can't take here the rook would
come up here this would be a checkmate
so we have Vladimir is not ready to give
up his Bishop here here does want to
attack this knight in the center of the
board King comes over here to f8
protecting this rook right here so that
you know black is free to take this
bishop here on f3 if Vladimir does not
do anything he does he brings his Bishop
here to d5 pawn to c6 then the bishop
comes back here to be three very common
square for the bishop to come back to
once you've castled on the Queen side of
the board something Bobby Fischer used
to do quite a bit you know many times
when he was playing in the Queen's would
still be on board we need to be playing
pawn to a3 even bringing his bishop back
here to eight who really controls this
long diagonal many times your opponent's
can forget about it and just has to
worry about this as a strong attack the
rest of the game
Bishop down to f5 just completing the
development from black pawn to h3 and
this is where things get interesting I
was not expecting a black to be this
aggressive usually you're seeing moves
like pawns to a5 just starting to throw
your Queen side at your opponent because
you've castled on the King side but
Fabiano says no that's not my game plan
I see an attack that I can start and I'm
gonna go ahead and start pushing forward
with pawn here to g5 forcing the bishop
to come back to h2 King to g7 pawn up
here to a c4 and then pawn to d4 so you
can already see black is trying to be as
aggressive as possible thinking that he
can maybe find something out of this
game not here to e4 Bishop takes rook
recaptures a Bishop to g5 check King
here to be 1 and then the pawn takes and
this is where things get interesting I
thought we would see a snap just take
right here I think this is fine from
White's perspective he's not too worried
about any threats going on in the
current board state but instead
of recapturing this pawn here on h3 we
see Vladimir comic play pawn to c5 now
as you go down an extended view of
different lines that both sides could
take it's not necessarily that he's
losing material it's the fact that you
know pawn to f5 forcing the rook to move
rook over here to b4 pawn takes on g2
white just has to deal with so many
threats in this pawn here on g2 is in
nuisance for white to deal with I think
it just is much easier if pawn takes
here on h3 black doesn't have any huge
threats white can easily just develop
his pieces as he would like to but now
we're up here to b7 check King to h8
pawn takes on d6 so it does have a
passed pawn of his own here on a d6
Knight down here to f3 it's pretty
devastating from White's point of view
the rook is now free to come down here
to e2 always gonna want to get your
rooks on your opponent's second-ranked
if you're black and if you're white you
can see I always want to get it up here
to the seventh rank they're usually
gonna have some material of sorts that
you can start to attack you can just get
behind enemy lines it's always difficult
for them to deal with also opens up for
an attack here on h2 and it is defending
the square here on it you've won white
is able to defend it right now with both
the rook and the bishop here on h2 but
still just the threat knowing that there
is a pawn that can at any point push
forward really keeps these pieces at bay
now white plays Bishop here to a4
attacking the pawn the knight goes and
takes here on h2 Bishop takes on c6 rook
over here to d8 pawn comes up here rook
down here to e2 this is a great square
exactly where Fabiano would end up
liking to be the bishop is now able to
take here on g2 then we see a rook takes
on F to a bishop back here to c6
protecting the pond he does need to make
sure that he can protect this past pawn
and that up here to g4 and then the rook
takes on a 7 so this is at the end of
the day the line
both players were looking at Fabiano
thought AF if you want to continue down
this line that's fine I thought you
would have just taken my pawn here on h3
well Vetter kromm Nick you know he
calculated out seven or so moves and
said yes this is the line I want to go
down I've taken my opponents past pawn
I'm gonna give up material here
in exchange for two pawns hey I'm gonna
take or I'm gonna give them a minor
piece but I do have a passed pawn here
on d7 it is gonna be interesting to see
how a lot of mayor Domenic can turn this
into an advantage most of his pawns are
back here on the second rank and Fabiano
can't easily get his material involved
he already has a pawn here on i-5 he can
start to push that up the board he has a
lot of material to help that as well and
you see white he does have both of his
rooks they are not connected so we'll
have to change up his game plan maneuver
around if he's going to have an
advantage right now I would definitely
give the upper hand to black we see
Knight to e3 this is a couple things one
it attacks the rook here on d1 but it
also opens up the door for an attack
here on C - you know rook over here to
see - and then it's also attacking the
bishop here on c6 huge threats rook to a
g1 and I thought for sure we would see
rook takes on C - hey if you want to
take my bishop that's fine I'll go ahead
and take your Bishop up here I I think
that's completely reasonable when you're
up in material which black is up in a
material trading down is not a bad thing
at all it really will just make your
your advantage even that much more
prominent in the game because your
opponent doesn't have enough material to
kind of overcome that right now there's
still significant enough material for
your opponent even if they are down a
pawn or two that they can actually come
back from that just from a strategic
standpoint but we see instead upon to
age six so is worried about the rook
taking here on g5 not sure if he just
didn't like the fact they could take
this pawn and this Bishop up here on c6
in exchange for his Bishop but decide to
go ahead and play h6 now we're over here
to c7
King to g7 pawn up to a four so
recognizing he needs to start pushing on
the board that's exactly what he does
pawn to e4 King to f7 and then Bishop
back here to a b5 it isn't outpost not
worried too much it's not in the center
of the board it's not the best outpost
but nonetheless it is something that
black has to worry about King here to e7
pawn to a5 a if you have a passed pawn
rule number one is push that pawn as
fast as possible rook here to f4 pawn c3
King to a d6 yeah I don't really feel
like this does exactly what he would
like it to do another option that he
would have here is rook to g4 just
forcing an exchange right here trying to
get down in material but decides to go
ahead and play King here to d6 why
continues with rook to b7 rook over here
to g4 now plays the move rook to e1
attacking in the Knights pawn to f4 just
pushing also has protection that he can
now get his dark squared Bishop involved
into the game one good thing that
Fabiano has going for him is that this
past pawn here on the 7 it's gonna
promote to a dark square he does have a
dark square bishop that he can protect
that if he ever does want to get his
route involved into the game and not
play defense
so pawn here on f4 is very important for
this outpost of the night here on e3 but
pawn to a6 so Vladimir continuing with
the game plan of pushing as many pawns
as possible recognizing that he has an
opportunity to just overwhelm his
opponent now black hasn't done too much
if you look at the board state 1015
moves ago you haven't really seen black
do all that much from his progression on
the the Kings side of the board here
pawn to h5 could have done his own f3
pushing that the pawn I think this does
give him options besides play pawn to h5
pawn to a7 rook over here to a 8 and
then pawn up to b4 pawn pushing forward
on h4 and then C 4 and this is where I
think white really should have decided
to push one of his pawns and promote
let's say
to d8 and he gets a queen okay well a
couple options of what we could see here
let's say the bishop takes here on d8
then rook to d7 check now
we're gonna see the King come over here
to see six can't take it because the
bishop here on b5 is protecting it and
now Bishop up here to c6 attacking the
rook and this gets tricky because
there's no great square for the rook to
go to it can't come here to be a it's
gonna be captured if it comes here to c8
then okay just the bishop could come
here and at the end the day the pawns is
going to promote that's not gonna be a
good plan so rook would more than likely
just take here on a7 we could see the
rook take and now all of a sudden I
think this is completely fine white has
gotten back into the game as far as
material he has the two rooks compared
to his opponent only has one I think in
this situation white is doing completely
okay but he decides to play c4 instead
does not want to push his pawn and
promote that right away pawn to h3 so
both sides you can really see how things
are progressing each side is they're
calculating every move they always have
to keep in mind that their opponents
pushing pawns as well which just makes
the variations that much harder to
calculate all the possible lines pawn to
c5 check then we see King to e5 getting
into the center of the board rook up
here to b8
now the pawn comes off the board I'm not
really sure I like this giving up your
your pawn you have such a strong pawn
here on a7 as well as d7 giving it up
just not a huge fan look over here to GA
attacking the bishop bishop EO to f6 now
the Queen comes up here to d8 but it's
not doing as much Bishop takes now the
work comes down in exchanges Bishop down
here to f6 rook to a g6 rook here to b7
both the bishops are now being attacked
but now after the rook comes down here
and takes on b4 see how different this
is than the current game state that we
had just a few moves go Vladimir Kramnik
was completely you know attacking on the
Queen sent aboard he has
pawns here on a 7 in d7 and just decided
to change up his strategy give up those
pawns for not too much on on the board
state he does have two rooks that thing
today I do think he had a stronger
attack if he just continued with his
game plans keeping these up here and
then continuing to develop his pieces
around the board
Vladimir continues with King up here to
a two-night to c2 attacking the rook
rook to see one Knight comes back here
to d4 this Knights just so active
putting so much pressure on White has to
really deal with every single move
Bishop up here to d3 rook to a4 forcing
the King to come back Knight here to b3
rook check where it comes here to e1
check and then the King comes here to d5
and yes it wasn't check and it moves
over here to d5 and it's attacking this
pond but more importantly it is opening
up the door for this Bishop to protect
this square here on a1 which is a huge
threat something that a lot of players
they wouldn't even see cuz they they're
just thinking how the king is moving but
now that this rook can come down here to
a1 an attack that is just another thing
that Vladimir Kramnik has to worry about
we see Kings who see - I'm not up here
to d4 check came back here to b1 now
Knight swings over here to f3 it was
blocking the bishop banality it is free
as well so attacking the rook also rook
can come down to e1 so so many threats
on the board really the only saving
grace that white could have here is just
try to take on f6 recognizing that it's
not gonna be the best exchange but now
the knight comes down here to e1 Bishop
down here to f1 you could gobble up some
pawns I think at the end of the day this
is gonna be doable for why it's not
gonna be easy it's gonna lose this pawn
here on c5 but I think you could
probably get a draw out of it but after
Knight to f3 played the very curious
move of rook to d1 not doing anything
there is a discovered attack that could
happen if the bishop moves here but
that's just absolutely not gonna happen
I
Vladimir Kramnik just forgot the fact
that the route could come down here to
a1 and this was pretty much the end of
it we did see you know Vladimir play
this out a few more moves but King here
to see two rook takes here on d1 Bishop
comes back here if we were to see the
King takes because somebody might look
at this and they say why would you just
not take well okay if King takes here on
d1 pawn to h2 is a dagger there's no
great way to stop this really you need
your lights for a bishop here to being
protecting the square but it can't do
that if the rook tries to swing over and
protect that well you could just have
Bishop to h4 this is being protected by
the knight there's no way to stop this
pond from pushing that would be a quick
end for white so in the game didn't take
the rook I mean no good move from white
here brings his bishop back here to a6
rook here to a d2 check King down here
to a c1 Bishop b2 check can you over
here b1 and then we see the King take
here on a c5 Bishop up here b7 yes this
is now attacking the knight here on f3
and subsequently after the night war to
move also attacking the square here on
h1 which is fine but Knight up here to
e5 attacking the rook rook here to f6
and then the move pawn to f3 just so
deadly just stops white from really
doing too much this Knights protecting
it so now now the pawn can push it's
blocking the bishop from attacking
there's just no way to overcome from
this rook here to f5 pinning down the
knight but sure that there's other ways
the black can stop this he can just move
is king if you wanted to a couple
different ways after pawn to f2 just
says yeah I'm not even worried about
what you're doing over here I'm just
gonna go ahead and push my pawn forward
with f2 there's just no way to stop this
I can't take the knight right here the
bishop is protecting it so you know
Fabiano Caruana has done a great job on
the endgame of coordinating all of his
pieces pushing his pawns he waited for a
long time
selves Lattimer pushed all of his once
and then he just gave them all up
Fabiana waited for many many moves to
make sure that he stopped any threats
and then and only then is when he pushed
his own pause and at the end of day he
came out victorious so Fabiano Cara
Juana is now in first place half a point
ahead of Latimer kramnik and so you know
congratulations to him he got so close
two years ago almost winning going into
the last round had an opportunity to win
so you know that he's looking to come
out victorious and play Magnus Carlsen
in at November but thank you guys for
watching out round four we still have
quite a few rounds couple more weeks
left of play but thanks for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video